il est le nouveau premier ministre de la
russie mikhaïl michou steen a été
confirmé à ce poste par les députés
russes le patron du fisc russe a été
désigné hier par vladimir poutine après
la démission surprise de dmitri medvedev
et de l'ensemble de son gouvernement à
michael michou steen s'est exprimé
devant les députés russes plus de
précision avec notre correspondant à
moscou
antoine gayraud tout a commencé dans la
matinée comme cry michou steen a
rencontré tour à tour chacun des quatre
groupes parlementaires de la douma il
s'est ensuite présenté face à l'ensemble
de la douma réunis pour l'occasion
ensuite la chambre basse du parlement la
douma a procédé à un vote qui sans
surprise a approuvé la nomination de
mira et demi justine au poste de premier
ministre je vous propose d'écouter sa
réaction
mais chevoleau thiney mesdames et
messieurs les députés de la tomate et a
encore une fois je voudrais remercier le
président russe pour cette confiance je
vous remercie pour votre soutien pour
cette analyse détaillée d'écran deux
options de notre travail qui vous
intéresse je vous promets qu'on va
entretenir le lien avec la douma d'état
les comité de la douma d'état les
groupes parlementaires et je vous
promets de donner des réponses
argumentées qui sont dans ma tête je
vais être plus correct en suivant le
conseil de mesrine au ski mais je vais
être très sincère et je vous assure que
je vais me préparer pour mon allocation
d'avril pour vous présenter le cours de
la fédération de russie et j'espère que
vous allez approuvé ce travail merci
beaucoup dont la foulée un décret
présidentiel a été publié c'est
seulement à ce moment-là que mira et
demi justine est devenu officiellement
le successeur de dimitri medvedev au
poste de premier ministre et maintenant
quelle est la suite pour lui eh bien ils
disposent d'un délai d'une semaine comme
le veut la loi pour proposer une
structure à son gouvernement ainsi
qu'une liste de noms de
ministres et seulement ensuite que le
président russe vladimir poutine va
approuver cette liste comme le veut la
constitution actuelle de la fédération
de russie
encore hier ils étaient méconnus du
grand public alors qui est michael
michou steen son profil en images
[Musique]
[Rires]